bonsoir
mesdames bonsoir messieurs bonne année à
toutes et à tous sur la proposition du
Premier ministre chargé de la
planification écologique et
énergétique le président de la
République a
nommé Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre
de l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
monsieur géralde
daranin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outresmaes Madame Catherine
Vautrin ministre du Travail de la santé
et des
solidarités madame Amélie oudea
Castera ministre de l'éducation national
de la jeunesse des sports et des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
monsieur Marc
F ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté
alimentaire madame Rachida
Dati ministre de la
Culture monsieur Sébastien
lecnu ministre des
Armées monsieur Éric Dupont
Moretti garde des saau ministre de la
Justice
monsieur Stéphane
séjourné ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires
étrangères monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires madame Sylvie
retaillot ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la
recherche sont nommés ministre
délégué auprès du Premier ministre
madame Priska
tevenau chargée du renouveau
démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement madame Marie
Lebec chargée des relations avec le
Parlement madame AORE berger chargé de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et de la lutte contre les
discriminations le président de la
République réunira l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement pour un conseil
des ministres qui se tiendra demain
vendredi 12 janvier à
11h je vous remercie